tengo 38 años soy mamá de 3 pequeñines
nací en collipulli en esta región hoy
vivo aquí en temuco soy emprendedora y
me dedico a correr pero no solo a correr
como mamá mujer emprendedora sino correr
como deporte y fue hace aproximadamente
8 años atrás que viví una de las
experiencias más emocionantes de mi vida
luego de empezar a entrenar seriamente
decidí inscribirme en mi primera carrera
que sería de 21 km por los senderos de
los volcanes del parque nacional
conguillío
quien me entreno para aquella carrera
fue la persona con quien yo estaba
empezando a salir imaginen cómo corría
aquel día
llegué número 1 categoría mujeres
y si fue increíble llegar número uno
pero lejos lo más emocionante fue lo que
aprendí de mí durante la carrera
en un recorrido en un día de tormenta
intensa subiendo la mayor parte del
tiempo porque la meta estaba en la cima
superando muchos obstáculos encender
rodeados de preciosas araucaria con
muchas personas y corredores alrededor
en algunos tramos y en otros tramos
corriendo solas
lo que no hizo más que sacar lo mejor de
mí de mí misma para llegar a la meta
cuando intento recordar aquella
experiencia lo primero que se mira en la
cabeza es el camino y no precisamente el
momento de la meta y el trofeo esa
carrera para mí fue vivir el presente
pero consciente de que jamás lo
olvidaría por las huellas que dejó en mí
para esa misma época en paralelo yo
estaba viviendo un proceso de profundo
cambio profesional como profesor en
inglés inserte en un sistema educativo
que para mí tenía muy poco espacio para
la libertad de acción y la creatividad
lo que me hizo sentir poco a poco cada
vez más aburrida e insatisfecha y
rutinaria y con la sensación de que
desde ese lugar yo no llegaría muy lejos
hay una charla muy famosa que dice que
las escuelas matan la creatividad y no
puedo estar más de acuerdo porque no
solamente le pase eso a los niños sino
también a nosotros los profesores
conozco muchos profesores con la misma
sensación y fue aquella potente razón la
que me hizo salir del sistema y fundar
un emprendimiento mini city que diseñó
juegos de mesa para enseñar y aprender
inglés a las escuelas a los niños
de manera lúdica e interactiva en
sintonía con la forma aprender de ellos
curiosamente me necesite nuevamente me
llevaría muchísimo más lejos de lo que
yo el cura donde imagines y luego de
empezar a emprender y los primeros años
vivir un camino muy duro muy difícil
difícil de imaginar lo difícil que los
primeros años de emprendimiento pero
luego de eso nos pegamos un tremendo
salto después de entrar en escuelas en
chile- y logramos entrar a las escuelas
en chino
y nos encontramos en tina con salas de
clases con niños que si bien tenían
diferente idioma y diferente cultura con
las mismas necesidades de interactuar de
comunicarse y de aprender jugando
para mí emprender es correr una carrera
de larga resistencia y a la vez correr
día a día es ponerme una meta tras otra
entrenando el aguante
correr y emprender me han enseñado cosas
muy similares y por sobre todo emprender
es correr porque del hecho que decidió
inscribirme en aquella carrera
esto significa que debería vivir el
camino llegar a la meta como sea
independiente del lugar y como llegue
porque por alguna potente razón decidí
correr aquella carrera en otra algo
tiene esa corrida que saca en mí lo
mejor para llegar a la meta
como dijo un amigo corredor muy
experimentado las carreras paulino se
corren se viven y si yo hoy día imagino
cómo es la carrera de emprender situaba
en 21 kilómetros subiendo la montaña
visualizo el primer tramo entre 0 y 5 km
en un momento en que todos los
corredores partimos muy emocionados por
el entusiasmo y por la adrenalina de
correr y partir todo en masa
con mucha velocidad pero inevitablemente
entre el kilómetro 3 y el 5 voy a tener
que bajar un poco la velocidad y
encontrar mi propio ritmo de respiración
de lo contrario por el kilómetro 5 me
ahogo y abandono esto simboliza en el
emprendimiento la primera etapa en la
que tuvimos que idear nuestra nuestro
proyecto buscar cómo encajarlo en un
sistema en un contexto y que tenga
sentido no solamente para nosotros sino
también para los usuarios su mercado o
quien sea una vez que llego a mi primera
pequeña meta que está en el kilómetro 5
aproximadamente me siento muy feliz de
haber logrado probablemente mi primera
venta haberme parado mi primera cima a
buen ritmo y voy tan contenta de este
primer pequeño logro que sigo corriendo
pero tan rápido porque ahora soy mucho
más entusiasmada
corriendo ilusamente más rápida creyendo
que por apurarme alcanzar el juego mi
próxima meta pero me caigo
y me caigo tan feo que como dijo un
mentor en el emprendimiento como tierra
comer tierra simboliza esa caída en que
duele todo y todo le tanto que sangra
que cierra la rodilla y en el
emprendimiento simboliza las altas
expectativas que uno tiene o que yo he
tenido al principio del proyecto
creyendo ultra enamorada de lo que
estamos creando creyendo que por ese
esto todos van a querer obtener los
inmediatos pero por alguna razón interna
o externa las cosas no ocurren así
porque naturalmente todo tiene su ritmo
el rendimiento es más lento de lo que
uno cree y esos duele y duele tanto que
incluso pienso en la posibilidad de
abandonar la carrera del dolor he tenido
caídas tan fría de emprendiendo y
corriendo créanme corriendo igual que
incluso ha llegado a verbalizar me
retiro hasta acá y loco
pero luego recuerdo porque me inscribió
en la carrera y vuelvo a recordar
también la carrera que estaba viendo
anteriormente y que no quiero volver y
pienso en todas las araucarias el
sendero maravilloso que me queda
desafiantemente por llegar hasta la meta
y decido a avanzar y sigo avanzando
lentamente me paro como puedo me saco la
tierra me limpió la sangre y sigo
corriendo
poco a poco intento re encontrar mi
ritmo de respiración todavía con poco
dolor y a por el dolor y por el recuerdo
de la caída pero de poco visualizo mi
primer punto de abastecimiento en la
carrera
esto significa que me puedo hidratar
puedo tomar agua comer algo y llenarme
de energía para poder abordar el
siguiente tramo aquí se pone cada vez
más duro
emprendiendo el punto abastecimiento es
vital tal como era una carrera en mi
experiencia significa la ayuda que he
tenido de mi maravillosa familia de mis
amigos y de que consiste en aprender
regional sin este punto ni un kilómetro
más hubiera podido avanzar porque un
punto abastecimiento te entrega todas
las herramientas para lo que viene más
adelante después de este tramo la
carrera sigue siendo muy doloroso porque
seguimos subiendo y uno va muy cansado
pero pasa algo maravilloso de aquí en
adelante ya no corro sola
otros corredores se acercan incluso hay
algunos que me dicen pauli baja súper
buen ritmo yo quiero el correr contigo
déjame acompañarte o juntos nos
inspiramos de otros corredores que ya
llegaron antes a la meta o podemos
ayudar e inspirar a otros que vienen
parándose alguna caída o partiendo más
lento que nosotros
y lo más importante es que aquí las
caídas ya no duelen tanto ya me para más
rápido ya no lo pienso tanto me ayudó
para amigo mi compañero ayudo a otros
por lo tanto aquí es avanzar
el último tramo este último tramo ya no
cabe ni siquiera alguna posibilidad de
pensar en abandonar solamente la meta
está más cerca y además lo que ocurre
con mi cuerpo es que mi cabeza ha
logrado separarse por completo de mi
cuerpo y de mis piernas y el dolor
físico en este punto de la carrera mi
cabeza solamente va disfrutando el
paisaje y generando todas las
herramientas para intentar enviarle a
mis piernas que van en otro plano muy
diferente sin dolor hasta que llegó a la
cima me paró y llegó acompañada
y observó todo el camino recorrido pero
una vez que miro el horizonte no hago
más que visualizar todas aquellas otras
metas que me van a quedar vivir o que me
va a tocar vivir lo que escogiera
hacerlo a causa de lo que he aprendido
de mí misma en esta dura experiencia y
qué es
deseo hacer actividades o acciones que
me desafían a mí misma de esta manera
todo tiene un sentido más real para mí
quiero hacer las cosas que me gustan y
sé que me gustan porque están en honesta
sintonía con mis habilidades debilidades
y características personales que cada
caída en el camino por más dura que sea
no han hecho más que pararme y empujarme
a seguir adelante y lo más importante lo
que aprendí fue que cuando le hago caso
la intuición me sorprendo de mí misma y
de los resultados
hoy para mí el correr es una actividad
vital del día a día en la que muy
temprano a la mañana salgo a correr y
transformó toda aquella energía
desbordante y extra que tengo como
hiperactiva que soy por si no lo notaron
y toda esa energía se transforman en
foco en atención en ideas toma de
decisiones inspiración
y creatividad y a la vez emprendiendo
tengo toda aquella libertad que requiero
para poner en marcha todas mis
habilidades y pasarlos bien finalmente
pero después de ocho años aprendiendo
aprendiendo también los costos que
significan la vida laboral e
independiente
aquella carrera es una foto de aquel día
de los 21 kilómetros marcó tanto la
manera en que enfrentó las situaciones
la manera en que decida o no inscribirme
alguna carrera que es realmente un punto
muy importante el jaime él sigue siendo
mi entrenador pero además el papá de mi
hijo hoy y mi marido y también es mi
socio en mini city emprendimiento
él con su característica es un pilar
fundamental para el logro de cada una de
las metas que hemos alcanzado y las que
nos quedan por alcanzar junto con el
equipo de personas maravillosas que
trabajamos
él es capaz de correr conmigo y
acompañarme en cada carrera que se me
ocurre inscribirme ya sea corriendo al
lado mío o donde me animo desde afuera
y lo más importante es que me ayude para
ernest cada vez que me caigo como tierra
emprendiendo corriendo o la vida misma
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]